uh okay
sorry okay we're gonna open up the
public hearing I mean excuse me the
subcommittee on Senate bill 85.
and let's see who we have here
okay
so this is still wrong this Sheet's
wrong
because
representative Gibbs you're on
all this time we still got
it okay
right exactly so this we're first what
we're doing is insurance right now we're
doing insurance so so I'm gonna cross
your name out of this one just so yeah
and
I yeah evidently
sorry uh sorry Mr chairman every time
those notices go out
um the people on the Committees are are
switched in correctly yes it was this
was the last minute change we made
between you and Sullivan and somehow
Kerry yeah I just wanted to mention that
I haven't got it fixed yet but okay
we're both here we're representing
Terry's not here
representative post
we have
purcelli
okay hunt
uh collabro
I did get it
text from Representative Vincent he's
just saying
and
but there's not gonna be any problem
here okay and
so he's not here
and represent Burroughs is here
and his kids here
so at this point
um
we're missing uh
you're missing one Dem and two
Republicans so
you're not on
this one so you're willing to fill in so
I I'll have have John because he's he's
he's just he says he was uh the text I
got was he was sick all weekend and
he it says it says he's on this one yeah
this is just this is the uh Insurance
one
but it's I don't know is it isn't that
too late to uh bill you don't you have
to make that decision you have to make
the decision 20 you know the day before
to jump
yeah I mean okay so at this point we're
going to pair
Vincent and Terry
okay they're both missing for this
subcommittee and so therefore the only
we're only missing one more Republican
and so uh John will
sit in for representative post okay I'm
gonna screw it out and scoot back
where are you going oh you have to go
well then you're gone then I'm not
appointing you I'm reporting
representative Waltz
yeah
okay all right so
okay so uh for 85 we had a an amendment
uh and that was the request so the
psychologists to be added to the to the
list
Mr Sharon may I ask a question yes
um why not go ahead with
um just making uh
the just getting rid of the requirement
for uh pre-authorization why does this
need a study committee
okay so as we learned in the public
hearing that the
um the issue of the
Mandate of getting rid of the uh any
requirements for uh approval from an
insurance company is unnecessary because
uh for all intents and purposes that
that has already been mandated and that
is when back when when we mandated that
mental health parity
existed that is matched to health care
when you show up in the emergency room
or if you have an accident there is no
need to have an insurance company uh
approve it so the only reason we're
passing this
and remember this is just the amendment
so that's in the statute that's in the
bill the only reason in my mind we're
passing it because it's already
occurring is that we want to make sure
that anybody who thinks
that they need to get prior approval
from insurance company that if they were
to read the law they would find out that
they wouldn't
not that anybody reads the law when
they're in this kind of Crisis but we
want to make a statement a message to
everyone in the state of New Hampshire
that if you're having a mental health
crisis you do not need to get insurance
pre-approval to get care
sorry uh
so I have not checked the amendment
against the existing version of the bill
uh my apologies but
um
so are we keeping that part of the bill
that provides that if a mobile crisis
unit shows up pre-authorization is not
required yes
so just so everybody and I know you're
new but it's just for everybody who's on
the committee when you ever you look at
an amendment
you always have to look very carefully
at the very very very top of the bill so
it says the mill amend the bill by
replacing section three
section one will be the title section
two would be this this
mandate that we're talking about and
then section three was the commission
uh thank you Mr chairman I I did
actually understand that as I said I
simply hadn't checked uh what section
three said I had not had a chance to do
that
um but that's all we're taking out we're
not taking out I'm not taking anything
out we're adding another sentence to
section three thank you
so nothing has been deleted yes
representative Spirit if I have a let's
say I have a what what might be called a
mental I guess emergency yes
if I were to go to a private doctor
you know call up my doctor and he says
well no you can't go to a therapist
right now you can't go to a psychiatrist
or whatever without prior approval
is that covered by current statute
uh well I I guess let me let's read the
language of the statue I don't know it
was
you know somebody who is familiar with
this issue would want to speak to this
question of that if I just called up my
my local social worker and and do I you
know will this statue help them the idea
is that we wanted to keep folks give
them another option rather than just
rush off to the emergency room we know
without ideas we don't want them to go
to emergency room so if I were to go to
my doctor
am I still allowed by Statute to get
covered without prior authorization uh
well the old statue was you you get five
visits without
prior authorization but so once you
state your name and
hi everyone thank you my name is Ms Vini
I'm the children's Behavioral Health
policy coordinator at new Futures we um
collaborated with Senator Bradley on
this bill
um I should note that I'm not a
practicing psychologist or social worker
so I my area expertise is a little
Limited in this section but I will say
that if you were to call your doctor
um and he is not providing emergency
care I don't believe that would fall
under the emerge the definition of
Emergency Services in this bill however
the point of that section is to include
mobile crisis teams which are a new
um sort of system in New Hampshire they
just rolled out Statewide recently with
the rollout of 988 so if you call your
doctor and you say I'm in a mental
health emergency your doctor can put you
in touch with the 988 mobile crisis
teams and then those Services would be
covered
without prior authorization to be clear
okay yes representative Gibbs
um okay I'm asking me a question or
asking her a question
uh
I'm actually responding to the earlier
question if I may
sure thank you uh okay something I don't
usually discuss in public uh but I can
tell you from personal experience
um that some such services are already
covered for multiple visits
um some are not but as I understand it
at least some of that is because some uh
such practitioners don't accept
Insurance
um uh but a lot of it is already covered
uh that's the best I could tell you and
I can't speak for every form of
insurance just the ones I'm familiar
with thank you okay
yes representative purcelli
Stan the tonight
you know Insurance types so would this
be the individual Mark I mean who is oh
well we can regulate in this committee
and by said what we can do is uh we are
affecting the what they call the small
group Market
and the individual Market
okay the uh who is not included in that
uh anybody who is Medicare
everyone uh everyone who has a large
employer
that is federally regulated and that is
erises
and uh ironically Rissa that the state
of New Hampshire
state employees are under a Risa plan
uh my County
Health Plan is an erisa plan
so we cannot mandate anything into erisa
plans but historically they generally if
we do pass something they then generally
follow suit but yes this does not uh
so it's a rather small
uh I would say it's a fifth
yeah so if you can call us about you
know at least a fifth
population but
I mean you have to remember Medicare you
know everybody's over 65 that's a whole
nother ball of action and and Medicaid's
100 posts here
okay
um I found another question okay
so uh just on the I want to be clear on
the funding
so we're establishing a study committee
to look at some of the how where is the
funding so that's the problem right now
um we have this new concept of this this
quick action team
um as you all probably been paying
attention if you read the newspapers the
big credit is we don't want
people having Mental Health crisis
showing up at the hospital
uh it's a problem you know the hospitals
I mean I have to say I I first hand my
mother was in a cardiac event and that
that was the room next door that was
someone having a mental health crisis
and she was yelling and screaming and
just it it no we just want to but so
that's why we have this quick action
team so the question is that one we know
that insurance companies we can are now
are covering this quick action team but
we need to how else of those other
four-fifths how do we make sure that
they're also being covered and that's
as quick as we were okay
um
all right so this is the wrong one I
technology
okay
so
um
so you're off the hook now because
representative post is now here
okay
so you're you're off the hook you're off
the hook cause right now right now we
have uh Terry and Vincent are being
paired okay
all right so that means we have one two
three four
five six people here
all right anybody would like to make the
okay
okay so what's representing Gibbs
all right any discussion on the motion
of the amendment number H
okay any discussion
all right see none all those in favor
two three five six okay six zero okay
moves uh to pass has amended any
discussion on the motion
six
all right we'll open up the uh work
session on the amendment to Senate bill
98.
um I guess I'd start off by apologizing
to everybody that you're only getting it
now
um I
kind of hope that we were going to get
it on Friday
but the procedures and process for
legislative Services is I think it was
done but then they had to re-read it and
they have to go through it to make sure
everything is working and that didn't
happen until unfortunately this morning
given the holiday or the Memorial Day
uh event yesterday
um and they also use the the budget as
okay so uh before I get into it I just
want to kind of set the stage where
everybody understands where we are with
this
um we obviously have no idea whether the
governor or the Senate is gonna
like what we have in front of us because
it's all new and improved
we do have a
representative Eaton's bill that we
retained which is very similar to what
this bill does
so that if whatever happens we know that
we have that action that we will uh we
can then come back in uh September
October
reworked that and be able to have it on
the house floor come January 1st the
first week the first week of January
foreign
544 house bill 544.
representative Gibbs you have a question
yes Mr Sharon
uh
some of the words
um did not print out correctly
um and I am looking at uh page seven
um section 318 F7 regulation of cannabis
uh the first line says all and then
there's a word that starts with p u but
I don't know what that word is and then
I have a more general question if I may
but what is that word purchase
all purchase of cannabis shall be made
by the commission directly so we're on
page
seven seven
and on page seven line
23 23
all retail Cannabis stores shall be
operated by the state of New Hampshire
oh oh the pay oh you know a lot of the
words didn't come through I couldn't
tell but some of them were but is that
one supposed to be purchased I I would
uh it I can see that the this is a
um this is a mistake of The copier yeah
John
I had the original somehow I ended up
with the original and it got expanded
when it got printed if you want the
original I have it somehow I got it I
don't know why uh and the words are all
in it
okay so what does that word Carrie
um
okay uh
what page are you on
insurance
I'm assuming that's classes as required
okay
oh it's all over it's all through it but
a lot
a lot of them I could figure out it was
just that one
because then I have a question because
it still says all retail Cannabis stores
shall be operated by the state and then
two paragraphs down it says the
commission may licensed persons who
operate agency Cannabis stores and it's
so I have to refer to the review uh
every page is wrong uh because the
backside it's missing the left hand side
it's missing numbers and and names and
stuff so literally every piece of paper
is printed wrong okay so it turns out
there was one there's only one copy or
one machine that's upstairs obviously
the PDF is fine so they're going to
figure out what to do but
um I I would have to say I I could not
go forward
with a uh we cannot you know the full
committee cannot take up this bill
unless we have a proper for everybody to
look at okay but in the meanwhile may I
ask a substantive question yes that
would be great uh okay uh you didn't
want me to talk and explain the bill
first I'm sorry you already know
that you you I might answer your
question
um well let me ask the question and then
please go ahead and explain I would
appreciate it great okay uh so we're
back online 23 uh but these words came
through forget about the words just tell
me what your what your question is okay
the question
all retail cannabis store shall be
operated by the state correct but then
two paragraphs down on line 33 it says
the commission may license persons to
operate agency Cannabis stores that
appears to be a contradiction okay that
is your question okay that's my question
all right so what we what we have done
um taken what is currently existing here
in New Hampshire
and that is agency stores
so I guess the first question is anybody
not know what an agency store is please
raise your hand if you don't know what
an agency store I know representative
spear learned about it for the first
time 10 minutes ago does everyone here
know what an agency store is uh do I
understand correctly that a store
licensed by The Liquor Commission so yes
they are regulated that and and the key
element is that these stores are located
in places where the Liquor Commission
would have put a liquor store
but because of their location it would
did not make economic sense for the
commission to operate that the selling
liquor out of that location so what
occurs in an agency store is that
um we the glicker commission is in
control it's you know they has a Liquor
Commission computer has a Liquor
Commission point of sale system it has
in the where the actual Liquors being
sold and so it is uh the best way I
would I would kind of give you a figure
of what they what they are is visualize
that at some gas stations they have a
Dunkin Donuts in it
and that Dunkin Donuts is being operated
by you know
by an affiliate by Dunkin Donuts or some
franchisee so there is or Subway does
the same thing they're in gas age you'll
see them in inside located like warm
every Walmart has a Subway or some
somebody else in there or a Dunkin
Donuts so that imagine that's what we're
doing is that the location these liquor
stores that are inside these stores are
actually
uh the rent and the facilities and
caught some of those costs are being
operated by
a third party
and so
um I have to admit when when the
commission came back to me and said well
what do you think John and I was very
jealous that I had not thought of this
in the first place because the agency
store doesn't have a tax there's no tax
because this liquor that's sold in those
facilities is still sold by the
commission they're controlling the
commission but they're in that location
so for those of you who really wanted to
have private Enterprise involved in the
sale of marijuana
that's what an agency store is
and so therefore it made perfect sense
to take the atcs
and resolve that issue so we wouldn't
have to figure out a fee or a tax or
something that that how they were you
know like we had when the original Bill
where we had the you know the 10 and
then 15 and then they settled at 10 and
12 and a half percent from ways and
means we don't have any of that because
the operations of these in these stores
it will be the Liquor Commission is
operating them inside these private
Enterprises representative spear
excuse me
and so just to get it straight in my
head The Liquor Commission still
operates or licenses licenses these
facilities correct but a private
individual can own it and and own it
okay you have in one place you have
slightly different topic
possession limits
where you talk about anything over four
ounces of cannabis and plant form and
possession that's under the marijuana
you know regulations that really not
later on you talk about
so it's illegal to have more than that
in your possession correct
a little later on you have a section
that talks about how the police are not
supposed to spend any effort whatsoever
going after anyone who's
that they believe may be operating that
page six yeah
no law enforcement officer employed by
an agency that receives state or local
government funds shall expend any state
or local resources including the
officer's time to affect any arrest or
seizure of cannabis or or conduct any
investigation on the soul bus
basis of activity the officer believes
to constitute a violation of federal law
of the office
Etc et cetera et cetera so in other
words you can't get arrested but you're
not allowed to have it
it seems contradictory to me that that
was uh having the police
um
make it an effort to go find somebody in
other words if you were pulled over in a
uh for speeding
and you have a joint on your dash of
your car
okay
at this point the that is less than four
ounces but if you happen to have a pound
of marijuana sitting in the backseat of
your car
and the cop can't fail to notice it
then yes they can arrest you for it okay
but they're not going to
uh set up roadblock let's say like we do
for alcohol where we have these where we
have to print in the newspaper and that
we're going to have them out there and
they're going to be stopping every car
and and you that's what they're saying
just don't they can't do that
representative Burroughs
okay I have a question if I have a
Dunkin Donuts franchise I have to do
everything by the letter I mean every
Dunkin Donuts store is the same you have
the same Donuts they they do everything
the same same amount of coffee yada yada
it's laid out the same yeah I guess my
question is if um the atcs are are
agency stores do they feel that they're
going to be able to run it the way that
they need to run it I'd like to ask Matt
Simon what he thinks
good morning thank you for the question
the opportunity to comment for the
record Matt Simon Prime Etc
uh I think we need a lot more
explanation of how agency stores could
work for cannabis in general before we
can understand whether atc's could serve
as agency stores
and I also just want to point out the
amendment in front of us is different
than what I reviewed over the weekend it
it actually oh yeah on page
for
uh
line I'm not sure because of the print
job but towards the bottom definition of
dual use
certificate
that says means license allowing an Etc
to co-locate with and operate a retail
cannabis store that's what it said in a
previous version I was under the
impression that was going to be changed
to agency store
this currently says atcs could operate a
retail cannabis store
which we like from a policy perspective
but
plainly contradicts the language on page
one line
29 that says all retail Cannabis stores
shall be operated by the state of New
Hampshire
and while I'm at it I think that same
line 29 directly contradicts the
language about agency stores as as
you've suggested would
agency stores are licensed their their
private stores they're licensed by The
Liquor Commission but the stores are not
operated by The Liquor Commission unless
I'm unless I'm missing something
so if atcs are to like to operate as
agency stores we have a number of
questions one
can we sell our own products that we
produce if so do we have to sell them to
the Liquor Commission and buy them back
uh that seems like a major impediment
particularly if you think that that may
be preempted and there may not be a
state-run system uh
with regard to selling we would like to
sell products from other companies as
well when I go to the store in
Massachusetts uh
they sell their brand and it's about a
third of the menu is stuff that they
produce and then they have 20 different
companies products that I could also
choose from and those that's the kind of
Market that we'd like to participate in
where we can sell our products and help
create a market for products from other
Growers and manufacturers so I can see
how the agency store model might work
with regard to selling other Growers and
other manufacturers products
I don't understand how our cannabis gets
from our grow facility to our stores
and I would love it if somebody could
explain that before well it's fine uh as
I told you before that would be done
through rule making between the
commission and you so if you
want to have that answered then I guess
we won't go forward with this bill
simple as that because
I guess we have a chicken in the egg
problem now
you want to know what the rules are
before we pass it
we don't have I guess all we can do is
create legislative Authority for the
Department to do a rule
but generally we would have to pass a
statute
for them to make that rule
so we have a chicken in the egg problem
Mr chairman I respectively would
characterize this as a problem of
contradictions in the legislative
language so how would you fix that
language to not have this question is
can I
can you will you be able to sell your
own cannabis
in this cannabis in your ATC to
retailers
at this point I don't know I I don't
know what I'm looking at I'm looking at
a very contradictory piece of
legislation I think that's uh perfect
that you've said enough fair enough all
right I I would guess that at this point
we can all agree this amendment is not
representative Gibbs thank you uh
this question is for you
um okay I am not sure honestly about the
procedure for
cannabis going back and forth from the
grower in The Liquor Commission perhaps
because of that this bill really isn't
ready to go forward honestly I'm not
sure but there is something that I think
we can fix
um and that is the language on line 29
of page one and the same language on
line 23 of page seven where they both
say all retail Cannabis stores shall be
operated by the state of New Hampshire
shouldn't that be changed to all recent
all retail Cannabis stores shall be
operated by the state of New Hampshire
or a licensed agency store or ATC that
would seem to solve
a large problem of contradiction
but it doesn't sound like because he
wants to know the rules well he wants to
know what the works are you saying that
one sentence that she just said would
take away your question about what of
the rules were necessary about how you
foreign
Mr chairman I think we've been clear all
along that we want Clarity in the
definition of retail cannabis store
Clarity and the definition of of dual
use certificate Clarity and the
definition of agency store we've
provided suggested language that would
clarify those definitions so that rules
could be made to accommodate the intent
but I don't understand how any
commission is supposed to write rules to
implement a law that says two completely
different and contradictory things
because I'm looking under the rule
making section
which specifically says the department
is going to generate a rule to allow
an agency store and it says retail
cannabis store are you looking in the
first the statute I'm talking about the
rulemaking section I'm going back to the
yeah
so
uh
if if uh if we want to it's I guess the
next question I have is is if we could
just correct this one sentence is this
the only sentence anybody has a problem
with
okay two sentences in this with the same
language in two different places so if
we fix those two sentences is everybody
no we understand that you that you and
we have a couple of other Republicans
are not too crazy about the bill
yeah
oh you don't like it
the cross
the process to me I've been around for
20 20 years here in the state house and
this process has been
unbelievable Shady it it's just not the
way we should conduct business I don't
know who's drafting these amendments but
whoever is drafting the Amendments
aren't part of the Cannabis commission
that was instructed to come up with
legislation that we could all pass what
commit candidates for commission the one
the one that that never did anything
well this oh that's right you want to
rely on the new Senate one right you
want the new Senate commission to take
care of this no there was a group that
came together no they were not a
commission that was an ad hoc committee
that came together that came up with a
solution right and that was a lot of
stakeholders and that was built on the
idea of private licensure yes yes so at
the end of the day
you the idea of the Liquor Commission
operating the stores is is uh right no
no no license but I'll
okay so I would say is that at this
point that's what this bill is and if
the committee does not want to go
forward with that then I would say we
just retain the bill
well we don't have to we can just go
past the underlying Bill and then and
just and we will do nothing with this
other issue and we'll take it up when we
do the amendment for Eaton's five
whatever Bill 540 yep
so actually I had their hands up first
yes representative Phil
I I appreciate the the concerns about
process and some of the concerns about
uh where the Cannabis will be sold but I
think we need to look at the the
overlying issue here of cannabis
legalization New Hampshire this is a a
long-standing issue and our constituents
are pretty clear of what they want to
have happen on this issue and they want
legal cannabis
that we can sit here and continue to
clutch our pearls over how we're going
to get this done
but we need to get it done and our
constituents have told us get it done
beyond that there's a social justice
issue here we have people who are
continually being arrested for what is
in effect a non-crime so we can quibble
about language we can continue to
quibble about where this is going to get
sold
or we can do our jobs get the
legislation passed and actually help
people who are actually being wrongfully
incarcerated for this so perhaps we can
actually begin to negotiate this
language and push this through or we can
let people get arrested for a non-crime
yes
okay representative it hasn't changed
I'd like to hear from The Liquor
Commission about how these agency stores
might work is there anyone from The
Liquor Commission present today I don't
see them here today they weren't here
last meeting either so that's kind of
conspicuous that they're absent they
they
um they are in an awkward position that
in terms of owning owning this
legislation
and um so yes I have asked them to help
me draft it
um but at the end of the day
um if uh if people are uncomfortable and
want to have more details then I guess
we need to do a road trip and go visit
an agency store and and uh and and
understand how they operate if we're
going to do that however I'm hearing
over here that's necessarily over here
I'm hearing over here
someone who said they will never vote
for an agency soar concept
so how many people that how many people
let's do this to that straw poll how
many people are adamantly opposed to an
agency uh store concept for and rather
have the just the private Enterprise or
I have the like the original 639
who would rather have the 639 and not an
agency store
I see one two
the original Bill the original bill
which has it okay
okay so how many people would rather
have the six well you can remember the
difference was 639 have that 12 and a
half percent tax
okay so how many people would rather
have 639 than agency stores
one two three four five six seven
eight nine
well that's pretty close to Ten Ten
uh look but Mr chairman
um the question at this point I think is
not would we rather have 639 yes I'd
rather have 639 but would I rather have
this or nothing because it's right let's
kill 639 right right well well actually
I'll be I'll be the
on this one if we don't pass agency
stores
it'll be 639 will have to literally wait
for a whole nother legislative election
cycle
for that possibility to occur and it
would have to as from what I can see
from this little lowly position as a
state representative that would mean
that there has to be a radical change in
the Senate
and it would have to be a change in the
governor
okay but that that's what you're betting
on otherwise do you feel
like representative says is let's get
can be that can be enough that should be
a separate bill maybe it could be
amendment to another bill that we've
passed or retained but this is not going
to kill if we have to wait two more
years
we have to make wait two more years we
wait two more years this is not the
right way to do it got it
represent gifts yes thank you uh I'm a
with representative filio let's get
something passed
okay
thank you
um my feeling is that given what
happened with 639 and the way it went
down I don't trust a commission to get
this right next year well the commission
that's been created by the Senate no I
don't trust it no no you don't have to
trust it you know full well they will
come out with this bill as as we're
looking at it right now but what I want
to say is given that
um I think I mean I probably shouldn't
say this but I I think that commission
will be stacked to get it the way where
they want it to go and given that I say
if we can get this bill language
um either now or retain it and do it
then I think that's preferable to
letting some Commission of who knows who
is going to be honest I would assume the
commission will solve this ATC question
they'll clarify that language I mean if
you think about it that gives us lots of
time I mean we'll have the time we can
we can fix all that language in this
committee than in a commission
right so we would then be able to take
it up in September and and but it at the
point what I'm hearing right now is it's
the committee is split on having agency
store versus having the private
Enterprise 639
not to split it's not your split you
would vote for a agency you would vote
for agency store if we could fix this
bill got the definition right right I
could live with it okay
okay so so let's take a straw Bowl if we
sit on this bill at this amendment until
September
and and fix it
how many people would be willing to vote
for it then it's a straw poll
one two three four five six and being
the fix is the language seven eight nine
ten
let me know okay well
we're close enough with that one I guess
uh yeah as you all know I I don't have
any compelling reason to pass anything
because you know I like killing Bells so
so at this point if we want to just sit
on this until September and see how we
can we can do it
um
and overcome that ten because even then
we're not really
fixing anything you know because there
will be plenty there's another 10 of you
which are not going to be happy with
that
but we are missing
we're missing two two members of the
committee so it's going to be tight but
we can certainly
jeopardizes pull your microphone
this amendment jeopardizes the atcs and
we work no no we we agree that this
amendment is not is no good
we agreed this amendment as it is is no
good because it still has in the statute
it doesn't say that atcs are
going to be
in these agency stores right up front
okay and that we agency stores want to
know what the rules are on how they're
going to be able to operate
right right I want to know before I vote
on a bill but would you ever vote for
atc's as agency stores or would you
rather have the original 639
639 right now and that's the question is
is that is that a black and white
decision I mean in other words there are
some people here I saw representative
Paxton Institute say that they like 639
but they would treat a compromise being
this agency store as long as it was
clear what the rules are for an agency
store that an ATC as an agent is an
agent did you really clearly have a
visual what exactly how they how they
operate
representative Sullivan why can't we do
a bill that addresses the very
legitimate concerns that uh speak close
to the mic why can't we do a bill that
represents or that addresses the very
clear concerns that are very legitimate
about uh people getting arrested for him
like we can do I don't see a reason why
we can't legalize something and then
figure out how we're going to regulate
and sell it in a different Bill like we
could do that that was that that's a
different committee
that was that was in in criminal justice
okay so if that happens and we don't
have to rush this part of it yeah matter
of fact that whole sections all of that
is just
they're saying oh well now that you now
that you now that you've now made it
legal to sell it uh then we've got to
cover that material but that is true
that's all there that's in criminal
justice and whatever happened to that
bill to the Senate table they
they table that bill anybody know what
do they just kill it
but
they haven't taken it up yet
yeah okay so that's still but yes that
is a separate issue I agree with you and
has nothing to do with this bill and and
frankly right from the get-go I didn't
even want to have that in this bill at
all because it I thought it would
cluttered up the issue but it just that
it was it was a Chicken and the Egg kind
of problem even I mean clearly I'm I
don't really love this bill but in this
bill I'm still curious why do we have
any sort it seems like it's still
illegal to have say four ounces of
cannabis or more
I mean if we legalize something why is
there a limit I mean if I we once we
legalize beer we don't make a I can have
12 kegs in my truck driving home from
the store if I wanted to good point I
mean why is it still seems illegal at
some level
so I don't know just another thing in
this bill which I think is another week
for uh for the libertarian Spirit you
might have
that this there is nothing when it comes
to regulating you know of Licensing or
regulated marijuana is ever going to be
truly Live Free or Die it's always going
to be highly regulated I understand I'm
I'm fine with the regulations with
respect to you know the same way with
alcohol we have you have to be 21 to buy
it you can't drink with it drink and
drive whatever but like here it sounds
like if somebody happened to
go to a store and it was on sale and
they bought a bunch to stock up and they
could be arrested because they had more
than four ounces I I'm just curious why
what is the logic behind uh well if I
were to compare it to the liquor
uh don't ever buy more than ten thousand
dollars worth of booze
uh because you will be reported
because of the cash transaction the size
of the transaction so you will notice
that and this has been an issue in the
past years uh with people who from out
of state
um I saw one at South Carolina license
plates and they were loading up their
Minivan and and then feeling it when I
drove by doing my my somewhat State
plates and and quickly threw a towel
over
uh cases and cases of Hennessy that's in
the back of their car unreported is it
illegal
well let me put it this way the illegal
aspect of that is taking it across state
lines okay that's fine but like we're
saying a New Hampshire resident who has
more than four ounces of cannabis could
theoretically be arrested it's not
actually legalize right so I mean I
think that I get your analogy but it's
not really analogous because that's like
taking something across the state lines
to a state where apparently that might
be illegal to buy it here and travel it
in but like if I wanted to go buy four
ounces I would be I don't know if it's
criminal uh I don't know if it's like uh
yeah absolutely true you can buy as much
Hennessy as you want right here in New
Hampshire why why do we except if you do
over ten thousand you have to be they
report you uh to I don't know the
Federal Federal Reserve ID you get
reported the fact you did this cash
transaction that's not really analogous
they know the insight into why we have
that that's what I'm asking for it's for
you to explain to me why we have this I
mean just like we have the limit on 20
milligrams uh of of a dose what's that
20 milligrams dose no I'm talking about
so I'm just saying that we're we have
other regulations that have limits okay
like we have a limit on how when you buy
this stuff how much you can buy I mean
other states so remember if I told you
what what I've learned about
Massachusetts is that you can only buy
up to 100 milligrams a day
okay I'm just saying so that's you can
limit how much somebody could buy but if
they're what happens if somebody's
caught with more than that does this
bill explain this I was only able to get
to page eight before we started talking
about it I just got it but like wow can
you explain to me what happens to
somebody if you're caught with 20 grams
of concentrated cannabis or four ounces
of cannabis like what happens to that
person are they arrested which is a
problem that we're all concerned about
um I would I would say
that right now the way the Massachusetts
law is I do not know whether they go
after the individual who was able to get
more than 100 milligrams but I am
telling you that they absolutely limit
the retailer I'm talking about but
you're lucky you're looking at the legal
you know what if you said to me let's
just get rid of all that legal self and
pass it in a separate bill that's all
fine and dandy but we can't pass this
bill until that one's been passed
in the Senate is has not signed it right
I mean the bill's not passed yet it's to
and and then and I will venture to tell
you if you think that the Senate would
ever pass a bill that you could have any
numeral number amount of marijuana
pounds of marijuana in your car it ain't
happening I agree I'm just trying to say
it doesn't actually legalize it because
you can still get arrested for having
that some quantity I actually I don't
know because you don't know what what
what would happen to this person either
sounds like like in my scenario you
can't tell me if that person goes to
jail if they get a fine
we don't know what happens that person
it's not in this is that where would
that be it doesn't say felony doesn't
say class I don't see any felony I have
to admit I never spent much time looking
in that section because that that's
nothing this committee works on that
that's a a criminal justice issue and
and
um it just seems weird to legalize
something
but it's really not legalized gotcha all
right representative Gibbs again
thank you
um okay I don't know what's going to
happen with that other bill in the
Senate none of us do
um and I recognize that the limits on
the amount are political compromise
because I think that may make it more
palatable to some people
um but
regardless of the precise limits on the
amount and personally I don't I would
say have no limits on the amount but
that's probably a political non-starter
um but since this bill is before the
committee
regardless of what
the criminal justice
committee does or the Senate does
couldn't we just strip out the part that
says
it's legal to have up to x amount of
marijuana
um just strip that part out and say you
can't get arrested for that and the
police won't search your car because
they smell marijuana which is in the
current Amendment since this bill is
before this committee if we just strip
out that part and leave out all the
complications about the dealerships
could we do that
so I would assume under our current law
now
you have possession issues I mean I
don't know what the possession law is
probably pretty low number so stripping
that out
we leave the current law that you can't
possess it so no trip it out and keep it
in other words just pull that part out
the part that
a lot of us want okay so people stop
getting arrested at least up to and
maybe four ounces is too small maybe it
should be higher I don't know but
because people are still getting
arrested and while this wouldn't stop
everybody from getting arrested at least
it would stop a lot of people from
getting I like that idea
right so that would not come to us
that's not ours no but I can take it out
of this bill we can take it all
completely out of this bill no I think
no I wanted to take it out of the spill
and keep it
in front of us now no we we would it
would it goes to criminal justice it's
it's our it's not our issue
Sean
so
if we were to take that portion out of
the bill I think
we need to legalize cannabis because if
you were to purchase cannabis at the
stores without eliminating the
prohibition of cannabis everybody who
were to purchase it at a agency store
would immediately commit the crime of
possession
we can't just pass the legalization of
this committee because we're not Crim J
however it sounds like an excellent
floor Amendment if somebody wanted to
bring that floor Amendment uh at the
next session and I'd be happy to
co-sponsor that with somebody if
somebody wanted to bring that floor
Amendment
um
why I think we can why I think there is
that limit up to four four ounces is
that we actually Place limits on
possession of a lot of controlled
substances and I think this would be one
example of a narcotic controlled
substance whether you think that
classification is legitimate or not
um I think is questionable but we do
place that limit on a lot of different
substances and so that this is just
another example of that granted you know
alcohol arguably is worse than cannabis
we don't place a limit on that but
there are arbitrary limits all over the
place in the law this is just another
one of those and I think that we're
probably going down a sinkhole that we
don't want to go down because we've now
spent 10 minutes arguing about four
ounces and we probably could spend
another hour doing that uh but if
somebody wants to do a floor Amendment
with me I'd be happy to do that but this
is not the committee to start doing
criminal justice because then we're
going to become the criminal justice uh
consumer protection and Commerce
Committee and I think we have too much
work to do as it is
yeah okay so I do have the the record
here uh so the uh the bill to
decriminalize marijuana uh was
originally voted out of the committee as
uh in expedient to legislate 11 to 9.
they were overturned on the house floor
210 to 160 voted to turn down that
motion uh the pending motion of ought to
pass did pass by Voice vote so we can
say 210 want to decriminalization and
160 didn't and when it got over to the
Senate the senate committee uh reported
inexperience a legislate and Senator
Gannon uh last Thursday the 18th moved
to laying on the table and roll call
vote unanimousness 24 to zip
decriminalization was laid on the table
what was the bill number on that
so I guess let's just put that aside as
a as a sidebar of discussion so what I'm
hearing is that this committee feels
this bill is not ready for prime time
and this amendment and that we so when
we go into exact session in 15 minutes
that uh we will not discuss this
amendment whatsoever we will just simply
take up uh the original underlying bill
so because this is just an amendment
so when we get into our executive
session 15 minutes from now
11 o'clock uh we will simply vote uh to
uh send Senate Bill 98 unamended to the
house floor will we make any effort to
fix this so This effort this will be
done uh basically where as you'll
remember uh we we have a retained bill
that is very similar language concept so
we will then work on that bill
and and uh and obviously we'll try to
diligently solve the ATC problems but
unfortunately there will be members who
will won't vote for that anyways and
that's you're entitled to your opinion
but so but it does look like it's it was
it was close that that people would want
to go with that but at this moment it if
we were to follow our committee rules I
would say that even we get down to
um this bill if it's going to be 10 10
come October then we will in a room
representative Gibbs so if some of us
had come forward with a new amendment to
SB 98 that essentially kept only the
parts that said Thou shalt not be
arrested for cannabis
this committee would not have taken that
up
that's it interestingly
um
we could take that up if you were just
to remove everything else and take that
issue uh and what would happen is if we
had passed that bill okay it would go on
to the house floor in January
and at that point the speaker will then
rule that the bill goes on to criminal
justice after it leaves this committee
and I would venture to say the criminal
justice committee vote will be in
expedient to legislate 11 to 9 and then
we will overturn it on the house floor
and pass it and we'll send it over to
the Senate and the odds are the Senate
will kill it
but we could not take it up so that it
could be brought forward to session this
June if you want to
do a floor Amendment and I I think
representative said he'll help you with
that there's nothing stopping you guys
to
uh take up any bill or if you want to
take up this one then we can leave it on
the regular calendar rather than put on
the consent calendar and then uh offer
up that Amendment and try again this
year but I would say you're probably not
going to be too successful when it gets
over to the Senate side
so you're suggesting that the best thing
to do is to continue working on HB 544
that was the other house bill
eaten belt yeah but in terms of taking
it out of Eaton's build which I assume
it's in there I don't I don't have it in
front of me I assume it's in there we
can certainly remove it completely from
the bill
but that will be the first reason why
someone will use why they would vote
against it that say is great you make it
illegal to sell marijuana but you can't
carry it you can't have it I wasn't
suggesting to remove it and get rid of
it I'm suggesting remove it keep it and
get rid of everything else
so people could go and buy marijuana in
Massachusetts come back to New Hampshire
um I don't think there's a lot of people
who are really excited about that
concept but I think that if you believe
in it you're absolutely have every
opportunity to do that but I I don't
think you're going to get that vote out
of this committee because that's just
not our Billy whack I mean that's not
what we do
that's this bill is not here because of
representative Bros
I would just say the one reason that the
floor Amendment might be a good idea
despite the fact that it's going to fail
is to remind people
um we're
why these bills are dying and to
remember that in 2024.
I know don't look at me that way well
I'm saying the bill is dying here
because we can agree on whether we want
to have the Liquor Commission have
it died in the Senate we had a bill that
we all agreed on here
right so that's not that's not on us I
think I mean I don't know what I think
about that strategy but I get the point
that right what people are going to say
is he you heard the governor was all set
and why didn't you guys why didn't you
guys come forward with what the governor
wanted
no because it's
well
we can go down that road if you want I
don't know like I keep hearing my name I
mean I can't you know all week my name
is popping up about this but so but in
any rate
yes Philip
are there any uh very basic anxious uh
bills coming up on the consent calendar
that you know of that would be ripe to
be pulled off the consent calendar say
to have a floor amendment to pull the
food right onto them
uh the calendar hasn't come out yet well
anything that we sent up on consent uh
uh well like I said we had
we had that other liquor bill which we
end up retaining
and so I mean you know in terms of
you're trying to find something to
remain
um only the Senate I mean the only thing
you can add on the house side at this
point would be the language of three
yeah yeah so because it passed the house
it has germanness so you could actually
attach that to any bill it doesn't
matter what bill it is you can attach
that to a bill
and and
um
but you do risk that the underlying Bill
might might die well if I'm looking for
something pretty anxious that if it were
to
if it were to die if it wouldn't be the
end of the it wouldn't be the end you
would sometimes pick up one that it
would yeah it's no big deal and that
part of the reason why I chose this bill
to be the one we we took this issue up
on because you know
it's not it's not it's not an
earth-shaking this is a pretty inside
baseball type bill
representative Waltz
maybe this keeps dying because uh
contrary to what my colleagues say the
citizens of New Hampshire do not want
this to become New Hampshire to become
Massachusetts Maine or Vermont
and I wish I had my pearls on so I could
clutch them while saying this but
uh I'm I'm sure that everyone that I've
talked to emailed spoken to reached out
to me thanking me for fighting this is
absolutely against the legalization of a
narcotic drug in New Hampshire no matter
how it's put in any bill in any form
whether it's sold by New Hampshire state
liquor stores or agencies or atcs so I
just thought I'd make that clear thank
you
just question of germaneness if there
was a floor Amendment if yeah just speak
to the Mike listener if there is a floor
so yeah the other bill is 360. so we can
attach that as a floor Amendment and it
would be Jermaine because it passed the
house but the language in this amendment
we hadn't we had a public hearing
a non-germaine public hearing correct
and so a subset of this language would
still be
attachable to SB 98 because we had that
public hearing exactly no it's not about
public hearing it after you it's about
um adding a non-domain amendment to a
bill right so yes theoretically
um
it had to be a bill that passed the
house already I'm talking about the
language in Amendment 2014. right now
what you were saying is if it's already
been World Germans since Senate Bill 98
could we could we could do that right
now
we could add that line we could add five
344 to to to uh to 198 or yes you were
right I I would say I would and again
sometimes Paul Smith's can
surprised at me but because we had a
non-germaining in that language was in
the original Amendment
that if we had this Senate Bill 98 ought
to pass it would be open to Amendment
and then you could bring in that
amendment that 344 Amendment
360. 360 Amendment yes so 360 could be
added to this bill
which is what I guess but you were
looking for representative Gibbs
okay
any more discussion on
the amendment to Senate bill 98. I I
just wanted to to follow up
um with rep what representative Walsh
says about marijuana being
um a narcotic I think there's I'm just
skimming through there's a lot of
organizations that just would disagree
with you um including the United Nations
office on drugs and crime the National
Institute of Health and many others so
Mr chairman okay
we're almost to the exact session so let
me just finish up a little housekeeping
here Mr chairman yes uh excuse me uh may
I also follow up uh very briefly
of course thank you
um
my apologies to representative Walsh
um uh the last time I spoke smoked
marijuana was 51 years ago
um I can say that as a hospital patient
I have occasionally been prescribed
narcotic drugs
um and I remember vividly the effect of
those and I can tell you that from
personal experience that the effect of
marijuana and the effect of uh narcotic
drugs uh that I took by prescription
um have absolutely no resemblance
whatsoever
everybody else all right
okay uh so right now the
uh has will uh let's say
representative
patusek second by representative
Burroughs moves
um to pass
okay any discussion on the motion of uh
ought to pass on the on seven pill uh 98
unamended
yes can you just remind us what the
original bill was what the original bill
was was uh to for delinquent account
holders your the fee would go from uh
right now it's a hundred dollars to 250
or not fee that the the if the
delinquency exceeds then it has to be
reported to the commission
pretty
pretty pretty inside baseball issue
no okay is the question clear
all right this is just the the liquor uh
liquor committee so all those in favor
of uh the motion please say aye
aye one two three four five six you're
and we're done
and
okay
yep
it just just out of curiosity one clock
says 10 59 the other says 1101 do we do
we average the clocks here
thank you
well it actually also there's actually
an answer to this one yeah see
that clock yes is in science and
technology
oh that's for the public this clock is
for the community is commerces so we
would don't ever care what that clock
says we only care with this clock so
we're behind them
so yeah we're right on time for opening
up the exact session
and we have two bills to accept the the
exec here
and
okay uh started out it was
okay
and uh
let me get so you have your exact sheet
or do I have
session here it is okay there it is
okay
so representative Burroughs second by
representative patusek moves
ought to pass on amendment number
2025.
and representative Burroughs is
I don't have I don't have the original
bill yeah it's just it's adding the
psychologist to the commission okay
who's lying okay so um we are voting to
amend SB 85 by replace oh no we're not
going to do no replacing you're just
adding
on page two line ten okay
14 in parentheses okay we are voting to
amend SB 85 so that we can add a
representative from New Hampshire
Psychological Association appointed by
that organization and
um
that's it that's it okay all right
any discussion on the motion about to
pass on the amendment saying none the
yes
the jelly yes
yes spear yes Sullivan yes
19 is him uh representative Burroughs
seconded by representative petusic moves
ought to pass
as amended
yes
Osborne
for jelly yes
yes
Burrows yes
Herbert yeah yes
mclear yes
okay uh do you want me to leave this on
the regular calendar or dad do you guys
do a floor amendment to it or
that's the other bill
oh that's right this one's all right
that's true okay uh all those in favor
of placing Senate Bill 85 on the consent
Calendar please say aye aye those
opposed so move unanimously okay now
okay
uh let's see who would who would like to
write the mid
Jane you should write the majority
report
a day or two okay yeah
represented below seconded by
representative uh Thaxton
just
you don't have to write it you don't
have to write a blurb okay
um
moves the Senate Bill 98 to be
any discussion on the motion of ought to
pass
only that we're not putting this on the
consent calendar okay we will leave this
okay if the motion is clear the clerk
representative Ammon yes
Osborne a Tuesday yes
Gary
yes
post yes oh yes jelly yes Paxton yes
walls
you're voting on whether we will let
raise the reporting requirements for an
on-premise licensee we do it by
subcommittee this is now the full
what was the amendment that was a
different bill
that was Senate bill 85. this is now
okay well I was confused so yes okay so
right and and representative Herbert
representative Herbert you would like to
vote Yes on Senate Bill 98. okay good
yes
collabro yes
Helio Yes Yes dear
yes
okay and we will leave this who's the
ones
she switched oh she's doing okay so it's
19 is it but we will leave this on the
regular calendar so that a floor
Amendment could be introduced to it
and with that
we will end our executive session and
so actually the one other thing is um
for anybody who has opinions about this
underlying build would you please email
the amendment to Senate Bill 98 your
suggested Corrections insteadable 98.
and theoretically you have been sent the
uh the
the the the the
PDF you got the PDF so so you can look
to that and refer to for that to that
PDF I will send you anything I can come
tickets
.com
um